in the middle of a press conference Joe
Biden cut it short saying he had to go
to the Situation Room to deal with
something and that something is
reportedly Iran striking numerous US
military bases in Iraq and Syria we've
got reporting now from Israel that Iran
was involved in the attacks that we saw
from Hamas the US is deploying the Thad
missile system into the region and many
journalists note that Hezbollah and
Hamas do not have ballistic missiles the
Thad system is Miss I believe it's
missile defense system it's for uh uh
stopping and intercepting it's kind of
like the Iron Dome so it looks like we
are gearing up for war with Iran call it
World War II whatever trending on
Twitter on X World War I we'll talk
about this and a lot of stories in this
area it looks like we're gearing up for
global war a lot of news reports coming
out that China is preparing for the same
thing